Transcription: Mag R
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je vais vous raconter une histoire
qui a changé ma vie.
J'avais 22 ans.
C’était une époque particulière,
une soirée particulière.
Ce soir-là, je me dispute avec ma mère.
Une dispute agressive, violente.
Agressive et violente par les mots,
mais tout de même très très forte.
Bien sûr, quand on est dans cet état,
on voit rouge, on perd toute lucidité.
Et donc, forcément, trop de fierté,
trop d’ego pour aller s’excuser,
pour demander pardon à ma mère
qui, elle, avait tout donné pour moi.
Ce qu’il s’est passé, c’est que
chacun est parti dormir de son côté,
ma mère qui pleurait énormément
à ce moment-là,
et puis pareil pour moi.
Sauf que,
cette nuit-là, j’ai fait un rêve.
J'ai rêvé que ma mère était décédée.
Vous voyez, quand vous rêvez les choses,
vous avez vraiment l’impression
que ces choses se sont déroulées,
que ces choses se sont passées.
Je me réveille en pleurs
en imaginant que ma mère n’était plus là.
J’ai vraiment ressenti
ce que ça faisait de perdre sa mère.
J’avais les yeux gonflés,
je cours dans la chambre,
je me cogne un peu contre tous les murs,
parce que je n’arrivais plus à voir
ce qu’il y avait en face de moi.
Et je toque à la porte.
Ma mère, je lui parle en arabe,
je lui dis :
(Arabe)
Elle me dit : « Oui. »
« Oui, ça va très bien, mon fils,
qu’est-ce qu’il y a ? »
Et là, la pression, elle descend.
Elle était encore là.
J’avais encore l’opportunité
de me rattraper, de m’excuser,
et de la rendre heureuse, aussi.
Donc là, je cours dans la salle de bains.
Cette fois-ci, plus pour la même raison.
Je cours parce que j’étais heureux
d’avoir ma mère qui était encore présente,
avec moi.
Elle me rejoint, bien sûr, parce qu’elle
ne comprenait pas ce qu’il se passait.
Donc je lui dis : « Maman, excuse-moi
pour tout ce que je t’ai fait. »
C’est vrai qu’on pense toujours au futur
et on oublie le présent.
On est toujours focalisé
sur ce qu’on n’a pas.
Finalement, on oublie très souvent
ce qu'on a dans notre quotidien.
Et c'est là le message que j'ai envie
de vous faire passer aujourd'hui.
C’est que la réussite,
c’est un état d’esprit.
Très souvent,
on va imaginer la réussite comme avoir
une belle voiture, devenir millionnaire,
avoir une belle maison, des enfants,
une famille, vivre à l’étranger,
créer une boîte qui fait 100 millions
de chiffre d’affaires.
Et cette réussite,
on va toujours la comparer
à notre présent.
Sauf que lui, notre cerveau,
ne fait pas la différence
entre le réel et l’imaginaire.
Mais à partir du moment où
vous allez être dans l’imagination,
vous allez créer des scénarios
dans votre tête,
que vous allez comparer
à votre présent actuel,
qui va perdre de sa valeur,
et donc forcément,
le présent n’a plus de
place dans votre vie,
parce que vous êtes focalisés, comme
je le disais, sur ce que vous n’avez pas.
J’aime bien cette citation d’Albert Camus
qui dit que tout le malheur
de l’Homme vient de l’espérance.
Ou encore : tout le malheur de l’Homme
vient du fait qu’il se compare.
Sauf que, initialement,
cette citation était faite
pour des comparaisons
vis-à-vis des autres.
Mais là vous vous comparez avec vous-même,
vous comparez votre futur qui n’existe pas
avec votre présent actuel.
En fait, en vous comparant avec vous-même
dans un futur proche ou lointain,
indirectement,
vous vous comparez aux autres.
Car lorsqu’on a envie
de devenir millionnaire,
lorsqu’on a envie d’avoir la plus belle
voiture ou de partir à l’étranger,
c’est parce qu’on l’a vu
généralement chez les autres.
Et forcément, vous dévalorisez
votre situation réelle et actuelle.
Bien sûr, à cette époque-là,
lorsque j’avais 22 ans,
je n’étais pas très studieux.
J’ai redoublé trois fois,
j’ai raté mon baccalauréat,
je me suis fait virer de mon lycée.
D’ailleurs,
j’ai fait trois lycées différents.
À l’université, pareil,
on m’a expulsé la deuxième année.
Il faut être fort pour se faire expulser
à l’université quand même,
un endroit où on nous laisse
tranquille, normalement.
Mais j’ai pris conscience,
après ce jour, après ce déclic,
que la réussite, c’était le présent
et que j’allais l’incarner.
Alors bien sûr, le travail,
l’envie, la motivation,
mais j’avais conscience
de ce que j’étais aujourd’hui
et conscience de la chance
que j’avais aujourd’hui.
Bien sûr, on va toujours rencontrer des
difficultés, des épreuves, des barrages,
des barrières, des hauts et des bas,
mais tout ça faisait partie
de ma réussite.
J’estimais que j’avais
déjà réussi, en fait.
Je voulais travailler
dans les ressources humaines.
Je n’ai pas trouvé,
mais ce n’était pas grave,
j’estimais que j’avais déjà réussi.
Ensuite, j'ai testé contrôleur de gestion.
Aucune entreprise ne m’a appelé,
mais pas grave,
j’estimais que j’avais déjà réussi.
J’ai fini par être
en master en ingénierie d’affaires
dans le monde des hautes technologies.
J’ai rejoint de belles
entreprises internationales
et ensuite j’ai décidé de quitter mon CDI
pour créer ma propre entreprise
et ensuite ma propre école
afin d’impacter encore plus le monde
sur cet esprit-là.
Et ça, c’est le message
que j’ai envie de faire passer.
Bien sûr, on n'a pas toujours
conscience des réalités.
Bien sûr,
après un long passage,
c’est toujours facile de parler,
mais lorsqu’on retrace son chemin,
on se rend compte que, parfois,
un mal peut être un bien pour nous.
Et donc ce passage avec ma mère
a totalement bouleversé ma vie
Je voulais vous le faire passer
aujourd’hui
pour que vous preniez conscience
de la chance que vous avez déjà à présent,
mais aussi peut-être prendre soin
de vos parents s’ils sont encore là.
Et finalement, vous dire
que si vous l’avez compris,
vous avez déjà réussi.
Merci. (Applaudissements)